the people of georgia are angry the
people of the country are angry
they're not taking this white house
we're going to fight like hell i'll tell
you right now
we will stop the steal
a week that began with an extraordinary
phone call involving baseless claims of
voter fraud
escalated to a pro-trump riot at the
capitol that left five people dead
and culminated with numerous
administration resignations and growing
calls for president trump's removal or
resignation
here's a look at how the historic week
unfolded
i won this election by hundreds of
thousands of votes there's no way i lost
georgia
in a saturday phone call president trump
urged georgia secretary of state brad
raffensberger to overturn the state's
november election results
all i want to do is this i just want to
find
11 780
votes which is one more that we have
because we won the state and flipping
the state
is a great testament to our country
raffensberger and his general counsel
pushed back on the unfounded claims
well mr president the challenge that you
have is the data you have is wrong
but president trump continued to double
down there's no way we lost georgia
there's no way
the rig that was a rigged election
but we're still fighting it and you'll
see what's going to happen we'll talk
about it
at a monday rally ahead of georgia's
senate runoff elections the president
repeated the unfounded allegations
and said that vice president mike pence
had the power to reject electoral
college votes at a joint session of
congress later that week
i hope that our great vice president
great vice president comes through for
us he's a great guy
of course if he doesn't come through i
won't like him quite as much
the pressure play put the vice president
in the spotlight even though legal
experts said he didn't have the
authority
to reject state results the future of
the country is on the ballot here in
georgia today
georgia voters have never had more power
than you have today on tuesday as
georgia voters went to the polls to
decide which party would control the
senate
the president tweeted and retweeted
claims of voter fraud which were flagged
by twitter as disputed
democrat rafael warnock will unseat
republican senator kelly lafleur
democrat john ossoff will defeat the
republican david perdue
and both of those senate seats are
flipping this is at the feet of donald j
trump he basically saved chuck schumer's
chances the victories gave democrats
full control of washington
on wednesday president trump promoted
and attended a save america rally in
washington
that took place just before congress
convened to certify president-elect joe
biden's victory in the november election
this is donald trump's republican party
let's have trial by combat the rally
concluded with president trump
encouraging his supporters to march to
the capitol
we're going to walk down pennsylvania
avenue i love pennsylvania avenue
and we're going to the capitol we're
going to try and give
our republicans the weak ones because
the strong ones don't need any of our
help
we're going to try and give them the
kind of pride
and boldness that they need to take back
our country
in the hours that followed rioters
wearing pro-trump gear attacked police
officers
smashed windows and broke into the
capitol building forcing lawmakers to
seek
cover and temporarily halting the
democratic process of certifying the
electoral college votes
five people including a capitol police
officer died as a result of the unrest
that afternoon president trump posted a
video on social media
it was a landslide election and everyone
knows it
especially the other side but you have
to go home now
we have to have peace some social media
companies removed the video and
later locked the president's accounts
citing violations of their policies
criminal behavior will never
dominate the united states congress
this institution is resilient
our democratic republic is strong
the american people deserve
nothing less wednesday night after the
capital was clear
congress reconvened to finish certifying
the votes
and back in session some republicans who
had planned to object to the
certification
had a change of heart the events that
have transpired today have forced me to
reconsider
and i cannot now in good conscience
object to the certification
of these electors the votes for
president of the united states are as
follows
joseph r biden jr of the state of
delaware has received 306 votes
donald j trump of the state of florida
has received 232 votes
on thursday several government officials
resigned
top democratic lawmakers called for
president trump's removal
and president-elect biden blamed
president trump for wednesday's events
condemning the violence what we
witnessed yesterday
was not dissent it was not disorder
it was not protest it was chaos
they weren't protesters don't dare
call them protesters they were a riotous
mob insurrectionist domestic
terrorist thursday evening president
trump posted a new video online
addressing the nation
a new administration will be inaugurated
on january 20th
my focus now turns to ensuring a smooth
orderly and seamless transition of power
this moment calls for healing and
reconciliation
he called the storming of the u.s
capitol by a mob of his supporters a
heinous attack
but accepted no responsibility for the
riot
friday morning president trump announced
on twitter that he would not be going to
the inauguration of president-elect
biden on january 20th
by the afternoon democrats had drafted
an article of impeachment that they plan
to introduce monday
the white house pushed back against the
effort and in a statement said
a politically motivated impeachment
against a president with 12 days
remaining in his term
will only serve to further divide our
great country
friday evening twitter said it
permanently banned president trump's
twitter account due to the risk of
further incitement of violence
a tweet from president trump's official
u.s government account
said twitter employees had coordinated
with democrats to try and silence
himself
and his followers adding we will not be
silenced
twitter removed the tweets from its
platform citing a policy violation
into the weekend authorities continued
to make arrests and seek information
about the perpetrators of wednesday's
riot